we have a voicemail number you can call
the voicemail number
really whenever you want and many people
call it times of day that are
times i tend to be sleeping but that's
okay because uh you can call any time of
day
here is a caller it is the eggman the
eggman has really been on an anti-mask
tear lately and i guess he's blaming me
for his
daughter wearing a mask listen to this
hi dave so i'm headed out on saturday
afternoon with my
15 year old daughter and she says oh
darn it dad i forgot my mask
and i tell her kid you don't need one
you're double vaccinated
you're good to go and she says well you
know i i know i don't need one but i
just don't want people to look at me
like i'm like ah
my kid now dave has the attitude be
that attitude because you and so many
people keep perpetuating the
wear masks even if your vaccinated idea
dave we got to stop this
you know that it's virtue signaling i i
admit that it's virtue signaling i know
why is eggman blaming me
know it let's move past this i want to
see somebody without a map
and not know if they're an anti-vaxxer
or vaccinated i don't want to judge them
by that anymore
you don't need to wear them anymore
that's what the cdc says
so um i don't know let's not worry about
hurting other people's feelings
shalom brother my kid's listening to
this so now i'm going to get judged
yeah well listen the eggman should be
judged and um i don't know what is going
on from the standpoint of parenting over
there
but listen i've said i don't it's almost
like groundhog's day here where i keep
saying the same thing
we've been following the cdc guidelines
all along and so why would we now all of
a sudden stop following
cdc guidelines what i have admitted is
merely for issues
of i'm making a social decision
where if i stick my head into a grocery
store
as i did yesterday and everybody's still
wearing a mask
i just put the mask on partially because
i get recognized at the grocery store
all the time
and i don't think it would be a great
thing for me professionally
if i'm photographed or seen as being the
only unvaccinated people in the grocery
store so
it's total virtue signaling i agree with
that um
but i think what the egg man's daughter
has learned
and this this is actually a great lesson
is that
we can understand the science we can
understand the cdc guidelines
we can feel safe not not wearing a mask
if we are vaccinated but
for social reasons we might say here's
something i'm going to do
just to make it easier on me some people
don't care if everybody's staring at
them because they're the one person not
wearing the mask
and that's one personality type but the
eggman's daughter
seems to have a sense of self where she
says you know
i'd rather feel safe either way
but just throw the mask on even though i
don't need it
just so i don't attract attention to
myself that i may not want
that's a perfectly reasonable
calculation to make in society
as i said before i never thought i
needed a mask to just be out by myself
on my bike on the bike path
but at the point at which everybody was
doing it i just did it
and it just made things easier for me
and there's value in that as well all
right eggman
little egg everybody i hope you're doing
well shalom we have a great bonus show
for you today
jeffrey toobin after being caught
exposing himself during a zoo meeting
is back and he's apparently been
promoted on cnn it's wild what's going
on
north carolina has decided to end that
really stupid coca-cola ban
you probably forgot about it but
remember when there was a boycott of
coke in north carolina because they
what did they even i don't even remember
what the controversy was they uh
crap what what did coke do they
supported voting rights i guess it was
or
i don't even remember we'll talk about
it and apple iphones will soon be able
to hold your id
privacy experts are on edge we will talk
about
those stories and more on today's bonus
show get instant access by becoming a
member
at joinpakman.com